Je vis et travaille à Tokyo au Japon.
Et je me suis spécialisé dans l'analyse des comportements humains,
en appliquant ce que nous apprenons, afin de penser le futur différemment,
et afin de concevoir pour ce futur.
Et vous savez, pour être honnête, je fais ça depuis sept ans,
et je n'ai aucune idée de ce à quoi ressemblera le futur.
Mais j'ai une idée assez précise
de comment les gens vont se comporter quand ils y seront.
Voilà mon bureau. Il est là dehors.
Il n'est pas dans un laboratoire,
et il se trouve de plus en plus dans des lieux comme l'Inde, la Chine, le Brésil, l'Afrique.
Nous vivons sur une planète -- 6,3 milliards d'individus
Près de trois milliards de gens, à la fin de cette année,
auront une connexion mobile.
Et ça prendra environ encore deux ans pour le prochain milliard soit lui aussi connecté.
Et je mentionne cela parce que
si nous concevons pour ce futur,
nous devons découvrir qui sont ces gens.
Et c'est, à peu près, comme ça que je vois mon métier
et le rôle de notre équipe.
Nos recherches commencent souvent par une question simple.
Je vous donne un exemple : que transportez-vous?
Si vous réfléchissez à tout ce que vous possédez dans votre vie,
quand vous passez cette porte,
que décidez-vous d'emporter avec vous?
Quand vous regardez autour de vous, que vous dîtes-vous?
Parmi toutes ces choses, que prenez-vous?
Et dans ces affaires-ci, qu'est ce que vous utilisez vraiment?
C'est très intéressant pour nous,
car le processus de décision, conscient ou inconscient,
implique que ce que vous prenez avec vous, et que vous utilisez en fin de compte,
a en quelque sorte une valeur spirituelle, émotionnelle ou fonctionnelle.
Et pour vous parler franchement, vous savez,
les gens veulent bien payer pour des choses qui ont de la valeur, d'accord?
Donc j'ai fait environ cinq ans de recherches
pour examiner ce que les gens transportent.
Je regarde dans les sacs des gens. Je regarde dans leurs poches, leurs portefeuilles.
Je vais dans leurs maisons, et on fait ça partout dans le monde,
et on les suit partout avec des caméras vidéo.
C'est en quelque sorte du harcèlement autorisé.
Et on fait tout ça -- et pour revenir à la question initiale:
Qu'est-ce-que les gens transportent?
Et il s'avère que les gens transportent beaucoup de choses.
OK, ça on le savait .
Mais quand vous demandez aux gens quelles sont les trois choses les plus importantes qu'ils transportent --
au-delà des cultures, du genres et du contexte --
la plupart des gens diront des clés, de l'argent,
et s'ils en ont un, leur téléphone portable.
Et je ne dis pas que c'est une bonne chose, mais c'est ce qui se passe, d'accord?
Je veux dire, je ne pourrais pas vous prendre vos portables si je le voulais.
Vous me repousseriez sûrement.
OK, ça peut paraître évident
que quelqu'un qui travaille pour une société de téléphonie portable demande ça.
Mais, en réalité, la question est pourquoi? D'accord?
Donc, pourquoi ces choses sont-elles si importantes dans nos vies?
Et il s'avère, d'après nos recherches, que ça se résume à la survie --
la nôtre et celle de nos êtres chers.
Donc, les clés donnent accès à un toit et à la chaleur --
au transport aussi, de plus en plus aux USA.
L'argent est utile pour acheter de la nourriture, de quoi subsister --
entre autres usages.
Et il s'avère que le téléphone portable est un excellent outil de récupération.
Si vous préférez la hiérarchie des besoins selon Maslow,
ces trois objets sont de très bons supports
pour les barreaux les plus bas de la hiérarchie des besoins selon Maslow.
Oui, ils servent à bien d'autres choses,
mais ils sont très bons à ceci.
Et en particulier, c'est la capacité du téléphone portable
de permettre aux gens de transcender l'espace et le temps.
Et ce que je veux dire par là, vous savez,
vous pouvez transcender l'espace en passant simplement un appel, d'accord?
Et vous pouvez transcender le temps en envoyant un message quand ça vous convient,
et quelqu'un d'autre peut le recevoir à sa convenance.
Et ceci est presque universellement apprécié, semble-t-il,
c'est pourquoi nous avons plus de trois milliards de personnes qui se sont connectées.
Et ils apprécient cette connectivité.
Mais en fait, vous pouvez faire la même chose avec des PC.
Et vous pouvez le faire avec des cabines téléphoniques.
Et le téléphone portable, en outre, est à la fois personnel --
et donc il vous donne un certain degré d'intimité -- et c'est pratique.
Vous n'avez besoin de la permission de personne,
vous pouvez juste le faire, d'accord?
Néanmoins, pour que ces choses nous aident à survivre,
il faut les avoir sur soi.
Mais -- car il y a un mais -- on oublie.
Nous sommes humains, c'est ce que nous faisons. C'est une de nos caractéristiques.
Une jolie caractéristique, je trouve.
Donc, on oublie, mais on sait s'adapter,
et on s'adapte aux situations avec une certaine facilité.
Et donc on a des stratégies pour se souvenir,
et l'une d'elles a été mentionnée hier.
Et c'est tout simplement le point de réflexion.
Et c'est ce moment où vous quittez un endroit,
vous vous retournez, et souvent vous tâtez vos poches.
Même les femmes qui portent des sacs à mains tâtent leurs poches.
Et vous vous retournez, et vous examinez l'endroit,
et certains parlent à voix haute.
Et presque tout le monde le fait à un moment ou à un autre.
OK, la chose suivante -- la plupart d'entre vous, si vous avez une vie stable,
je veux dire par là si vous ne voyagez pas tout le temps, d'hôtel en hôtel-
mais la plupart des gens ont ce que l'on appelle un centre de gravité.
Et un centre de gravité, c'est l'endroit où vous gardez toutes ces choses.
Et ces objets ne restent pas dans le centre de gravité,
mais, avec le temps, ils gravitent là.
C'est là que l'on s'attend à trouver ses affaires.
Et en fait, quand vous vous retournez,
et que vous regardez dans la maison,
à la recherche de vos affaires,
c'est là que vous regardez en premier, d'accord?
OK, donc quand on a fait cette étude,
on a trouvé la solution garantie à 100%,
de ne plus jamais oublier quelque chose.
Et c'est, assez simplement, de ne rien avoir à se rappeler.
(Rires)
OK, ça ressemble à l'horoscope que vous trouvez dans les gâteaux de riz chinois, n'est-ce-pas?
Mais c'est en fait l'art de déléguer.
Et du point de vue du design,
c'est comprendre ce que l'on peut déléguer à la technologie
et ce que vous pouvez confier à d'autres personnes.
Et il semblerait que , si vous le voulez bien, déléguer
peut devenir la solution pour pratiquement tous les problèmes
exceptées des choses comme les fonctions corporelles, aller aux toilettes.
Vous ne pouvez demander à personne de le faire à votre place.
Et exceptées des choses comme les divertissements,
vous ne voudriez pas payer quelqu'un pour aller au cinéma et s'amuser à votre place .
Ou, en tout cas, par pour l'instant.
Peut-être un jour, dans le futur, nous pourrons le faire.
Donc, je vous donne un exemple pratique de délégation, d'accord.
Voici probablement le sujet qui me passionne le plus,
c'est la recherche que nous avons réalisée sur l'illettrisme
et la façon dont les personnes illettrées communiquent .
L'ONU a estimé, ce sont des chiffres de 2004,
qu'il y a presque 800 millions de personnes qui ne savent ni lire ni écrire, dans le monde entier.
Nous avons donc mené plusieurs recherches.
Et une des choses que nous avons observées --
si vous ne savez ni lire ni écrire,
et que vous voulez communiquer sur de longues distances,
vous avez besoin d'identifier la personne
avec qui vous souhaitez communiquer.
Ce pourrait être un numéro de téléphone, une adresse email,
ou encore une adresse postale.
Question simple, si vous ne savez ni lire ni écrire,
comment gérez-vous vos contacts?
Et le fait est que des millions de gens le font.
Si on considère seulement la perspective du design, on n'a pas vraiment compris comment ils y arrivent,
et c'est seulement un petit exemple
des recherches que nous avons faites.
Et il apparait que les personnes illettrées sont experts en délégation.
Ils délèguent donc une partie de la tâche à d'autres,
ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire eux-mêmes.
Laissez-moi vous donner un autre exemple de délégation.
Celui-ci est un peu plus sophistiqué,
et provient d'une étude réalisée en Ouganda
sur la manière dont les gens se servent du matériel qu'ils possèdent en commun.
"Sente" est un mot qui signifie "argent" en Ouganda.
Il a une autre signification, qui est est d'envoyer de l'argent sous forme de temps d'antenne, OK?
Et voici comment ça fonctionne.
Disons que June, tu es dans un village, un village rural.
Je suis à Kampala et c'est moi qui suis salarié.
Je renvoie de l'argent et ça fonctionne comme ceci.
Dans ton village, une personne a le téléphone,
et c'est l'opérateur du kiosque téléphone.
Et c'est probable qu'il n'y ait qu'un simple téléphone portable au kiosque.
Ce que je vais faire, c'est que je vais acheter une carte prépayée comme celle-ci.
Et au lieu de l'utiliser pour recharger mon propre portable,
j'appelle l'opérateur du village.
Je leur lis le numéro et ça leur permet de recharger leur téléphone.
Donc ils rechargent leur crédit grâce à Kampala
et c'est maintenant utilisable par le village.
On prend une commission de 10 à 20%, et on --
l'opérateur du kiosque prend une commission de 10 à 20 %,
et vous passe le reste en cash.
OK, et il y a deux choses qui me plaisent ici.
La première, c'est que tous ceux qui ont accès à un téléphone portable,
à un téléphone portable,
se transforment en Distributeur Automatique de Billets.
Ça fournit des services bancaires rudimentaires à des endroits
qui en sont dépourvus.
Et même s'ils avaient accès à une infrastructure bancaire,
ils ne seraient pas nécessairement considérés comme des clients viables,
car ils ne sont pas assez riches pour avoir des comptes en banque.
Il y a une deuxième chose positive aussi.
Malgré toutes les ressources dont je dispose,
et malgré toute la sophistication apparente,
je sais que je n'aurais jamais créé quelque chose d'aussi élégant
et autant en phase avec les conditions locales. OK?
Et, oui, il existe la Banque Grameen et le micro-crédit.
Mais la différence
c'est qu'aucune autorité centrale n'essaie de contrôler ce disopositif
C'est une innovation issue de la rue.
Il apparaît que la rue est une source inépuisable
d'inspiration pour nous.
Et certes, si vous cassez un de ces objets ici, vous le rendez au fournisseur.
Il vous en donne un nouveau.
Et peut-être même trois nouveaux, d'accord?
Je pense aux offres "pour trois achetés, le quatrième est offert"
Si vous allez dans les rues en Inde et en Chine, vous verrez ce genre de choses.
Et c'est là qu'ils récupèrent ce qui est cassé,
ils le réparent, et le remettent en circulation.
Voici un poste de travail à Jilin City, en Chine,
et vous voyez des gens démonter un téléphone
puis le remonter.
Ils inversent le manuel de fabrication.
C'est une sorte de manuel pirate,
et il est écrit en Chinois et en Anglais.
Ils les écrivent aussi en Hindi.
Vous pouvez vous y abonner.
Il existe des instituts de formation où ils forment aussi
des gens à réparer ces objets.
Ce qui me plaît ici,
c'est que ça se résume à quelqu'un dans la rue , muni d'une petite surface plane,
d'un tournevis, d'une brosse à dents pour nettoyer les contacteurs,
car ils sont souvent couverts de poussière, et des connaissances.
Et tout le réseau social de la connaissance est là tout autour.
Et j'aime bien ça car ça remet en cause toute la façon dont nous concevons le matériel,
dont nous le construisons, et potentiellement le distribuons.
Ça remet en cause les normes.
OK, pour moi la rue soulève tant de questions différentes.
Par exemple, voici du Viagra que j'ai acheté dans un sex shop en Chine.
Et la Chine est un pays où l'on trouve beaucoup de contrefaçons.
Et je sais ce que vous vous dîtes, est-ce que je l'ai testé?
Je ne vais pas vous répondre, OK.
Mais j'examine ceci, et je réfléchis aux implications
de confiance dans le processus d'achat,
et on voit ça et on pense, comment est-ce que ça marche,
par exemple, pour la conception du produit. Les leçons qu'on en retire
s'appliquent à la conception de services en ligne, les services du futur sur ces marchés?
Voici un sous-vêtement de --
(rires)
du Tibet.
Et quand je vois ça, honnêtement,je me demande
pourquoi on concevrait des sous-vêtements avec une poche, d'accord?
Et quand je vois ça, je me demande
si on reprenais toute la fonctionnalité de produits comme celui-ci,
on les répartissait sur tout le corps
comme une sorte de réseau personnel,
que placerions-nous en premier?
Et oui, c'est assez trivial, mais en fait on peut tirer des enseignements qui
s'appliquent à des sortes de réseaux personnels.
Voici quelques numéros de téléphone
écrits dans une cabane en Ouganda.
Ils n'ont pas de numéros de rue, mais des numéros de téléphone.
Donc, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire, quand l'identité des gens se définit par un portable?
Quand l'identité des plus de trois milliards de gens est mobile, elle n'est pas fixe?
Votre notion de l'identité est déjà dépassée, OK,
pour ces trois milliards de personnes.
C'est comme ça que ça change.
Et j'arrive sur cette image, qui est celle avec laquelle j'ai commencé.
Et ça vient, ça vient de Delhi.
Ça provient d'une étude que nous avions faite sur l'illettrisme,
et c'est un type dans une boutique de thé.
On peut voir le chai servi à l'arrière-plan.
Et c'est un travailleur vraiment très pauvre
sur les barreaux les plus bas de l'échelle sociale.
Et en quelque sorte, il sait apprécier
les valeurs de "LiveStrong".
Ce ne sont pas nécessairement les mêmes valeurs,
mais une partie de leurs valeurs,
au point d'aller se les procurer
et de les afficher.
Pour moi, cela personnifie ce monde interconnecté,
où tout est lié, et les points --
tous les points se rejoignent.
OK, le titre de cette présentation est"connections et conséquences",
et c'est vraiment une sorte de résumé de 5 années à se demander
comment ce sera quand tout le monde sur cette planète
aura la possibilité de transcender l'espace et le temps
d'une manière personnelle et qui lui convienne?
Quand tout le monde sera connecté.
Et il y a quatre choses.
La première, c'est l'immédiateté des idées,
la vitesse à laquelle elles circulent.
Et je sais que TED soutient les grandes idées,
mais en réalité, la notion de grande idée est en train de changer.
Si vous voulez répandre une grande idée, vous devez toucher tout le monde sur la planète,
c'est la première chose.
La seconde, c'est l'immédiateté des objets.
Et ce que je veux dire par là, c'est qu'ils deviennent de plus en plus petits,
alors que les fonctionnalités auxquelles vous accédez ne cessent de croître-
des services comme la banque, l'identité --
ces choses se déplacent très rapidement dans le monde entier.
Et donc la rapidité d'adoption de ces choses
va devenir de plus en plus grande
à tel point qu'on ne peut même pas le concevoir,
quand vous le rapportez à 6,3 milliards
et à l'augmentation de la population mondiale.
La chose suivante, c'est que, quelque soit la façon de concevoir ce matériel -
avec toute l'attention que nous mettons dans la conception --
la rue s'en emparera et trouvera des moyens de la faire progresser,
dès l'instant où ce matériel satisfait un réel besoin.
La possibilité de transcender le temps et l'espace, par exemple.
Et on ne peut pas anticiper les prochaines innovations.
Car malgré nos ressources, ils feront mieux que nous
C'est mon sentiment.
Et si on est intelligent, on observera ce qui se passe,
et on trouvera un moyen de s'en inspirer
pour ce que l'on crée et la manière dont on crée.
Et la dernière chose-en fait vers qui on dirige la conversation.
Ces trois milliards de personnes connectées en plus,
veulent faire partie de la conversation.
Et je pense que notre pertinence et celle de TED
c'est vraiment de suivre cela et d'apprendre à écouter, essentiellement.
Et on doit apprendre à écouter
Merci, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)